[Music]
building a real-time chat app used to be
something that would take at least weeks
of development time but with firebase it
becomes almost trivial because the SDK
handles all the state management and
data syncing in between the client and
server for you it's so easy in fact that
I built an entire chat app in the last
24 hours that you can use right now and
over the next few minutes I'll show you
exactly how I built it using an angular
fire and fire store if you're just
finding the channel like and subscribe
and if you leave a comment below you'll
have a chance to win either a sticker or
a t-shirt on the livestream later this
week now the first thing I want to talk
about in this video is data modeling
because there's no one-size-fits-all for
every chat feature the first thing every
app will need is a user authentication
system and then some public user profile
information saved in a user's collection
and firestore that's pretty
straightforward but you have a lot of
different options when it comes to
modeling the relationship between users
chats and individual messages
I think the logical first approach that
most people would take is to set up a
collection of chats and then for each of
these chats create a sub collection of
messages this is a good way to go
because you can save all of your chat
metadata on one small document and then
query as many messages as you need from
the sub collection and as an alternative
you might make this a root collection so
you can query the messages across all of
the different chats throughout your
application for example a root
collection will allow you to query all
the messages for a specific user across
all the different chats that they're
participating in I think this approach
is the most flexible but the drawback is
that you need to execute a document read
for every message that you show in the
UI in this video we're going to take a
completely different approach by
modeling each chat as its own document
and then embedding the messages for that
chat on the document this method is fast
and simple but there are some
limitations first we can no longer query
the individual messages because they're
embedded on the document we can only
sort them client side and the second
thing is that documents are limited to
one megabyte of data which is
conservatively somewhere between 250 and
a thousand messages per document to
address this limitation will set up a
cloud function that will either archive
or delete older messages and this has
the added benefit of keeping the
document size relatively small so
the initial load should always be very
performant if we look at the actual
database you can see that each chat has
an owner and then each individual
message is an object inside this
messages array it contains the user ID a
created at timestamp and the message
content when a user is logged in and
they create a new chat it will create
this document with their user ID as the
owner ID this will give us a URL that
the user can then share so other
authenticated users can use this link
and then participate in the chat
currently all the chats are public but
check out episode 75 if you want to
learn more about user authorization and
firestore now let's get to building this
thing the first thing you'll need is an
angular app with angular fire and
firebase installed I'm not going to
cover every single line of code in
detail but you can find the full source
code on angular firebase com we have
three main resources in our code that
we'll focus on the first one is our
authentication service which gets that
user logged in and saves their
information a firestorm then we have a
chat service which handles all the
interaction with the chat like creating
new ones and adding messages to it and
then we have a chat component which
handles displaying the actual chat
information in the UI the chat component
will be loaded by the angular router and
you can see here that it's nested under
a dynamic ID so we can save each chat
under its own unique URL the first thing
we'll look at is the auth service and
we're not going to go through it line by
line but I just want to show you
generally what's going on you can get a
more detailed explanation in episode 55
the first thing we're doing is we're
listening to the angular fire off state
which is the currently authenticated
user and then we're going into fire
store and grabbing a related user
document with their profile information
then we also have a handful of methods
to sign the user in with Google and also
sign out and the one unique line of code
that you'll see throughout this video is
this get user method which converts that
user observable to a promise so we can
later use it with async await this is
just much easier to work with when it
comes to writing data to fire store so
now that we have a way to manage user
data we're going to go into our chat
service and build out the actual methods
that control our chat the service will
use angular fire store along with our
off service the router and we'll also
import fire store directly from firebase
app the first method we'll write is get
chat which just retrieves a chat
document from the
store database we're going to want the
chat document to be retrieved as an
observable because it will be constantly
changing and we'll also want to tell
angularfire to map the document ID along
with the data payload as the final
result from this observable this will
just make it easier to pass the document
ID around once we get to the main
component here in a few minutes the next
method create will add a new document to
the database we can make it an async
function because all right methods in
firebase are promise based when we fire
this create method we want to ensure
that we have the currently authenticated
users user ID we can get it by awaiting
the promise and then we'll set up a data
payload here with the user ID a
timestamp and then also an empty array
of messages from there it's just a
matter of making a reference to the
chats collection and then we'll call the
add method to add this data as a new
document when that operation is complete
we'll go ahead and use the angular
router to navigate to the URL with that
chat ID that takes care of creating a
new chatroom adding in messages to the
chat follows a very similar process
well once again create an async function
that takes the chat ID and the message
content as an argument then we'll
determine the current users ID with our
get user method and then we'll set up a
data payload with the user ID the
content and a created at timestamp we're
going to use a relatively new method and
firestore which is the array union
method it changes the behavior of
updates when working with arrays so if
we have a unique object it's going to
append that object to the end of the
array the nice thing about this is that
it ensures every messages unique and
item potent in other words if we
accidentally submit the same data
payload twice only one of those objects
will actually be added to the chat array
and that's actually a really nice
advantage over working with a dedicated
collection for your messages the last
thing I'm going to show you here
requires some pretty advanced rxjs
knowledge if you get completely lost
with this code it's understandable and I
recommend that you watch my firestore
joins video to get a better idea of
what's going on here so the purpose of
this method is to join the user profiles
to the individual chat messages this
will ensure that our chat messages
always show the most recent user profile
image and user name on the message
itself this can get pretty complex
because the user can post multiple
messages to
single chatroom but we don't want to
redundantly read their profile data over
and over again so what we do is we take
the original chat document and find all
of the unique user id's within that
messages array then we read all those
user profiles concurrently using the
combined latest method and lastly we
recompose the original messages object
so that every message also has a user
property with the user profile data the
end result is that we have a single
object that has all the chat messages
and all the user profiles and everything
is synced up in real time so that takes
care of us the hard stuff now we can get
into the chat component and build out
the UI this component will depend on our
chat service and also activated route
from the angular router we have two
properties on this component we have the
chat observable which is the actual data
that we want to show in the UI and then
new message which is the form input that
the user will enter to add a new message
to the chat now because this component
is loaded by the angular router we can
grab the document ID using activated
route which we do by saying route
snapshot / am map get ID we can use that
ID to first set up a source observable
of the chat messages and you could just
stop at this point if you only need the
messages but we also want to join the
users to this original observable so
we'll set up the chat property as the
observable returned from the join users
method for this demo I'm just going to
use the most basic type of form that you
can use an angular which is an NG model
form these are also called template
driven forms and basically we're just
going to take the value from a form
input and send it to our send message
method which will update firestore and
the last little tip here is that
whenever working with a real-time array
and looping over it in angular you
should set up a track by method this
just tells angular to only rerender
items that have changed and it will
dramatically improve the user experience
and performance now we can switch over
to the HTML and we'll set up an NG if
statement that unwraps that chat
observable you'll notice I'm doing this
on an NG container which allows us to
set up a context in this template
without actually rendering any Dom
elements so once our chat observable
data is ready we can just use it as this
chat variable throughout the template
from there I'll set up an NG for loop
and loop over the messages in the chat
messages array because they're all
embedded on the document we don't have
to wait for anything asynchronous
and this is the point where we'll also
want to use our track by function from
there we'll have access to the message
itself plus some information about the
user and the final step is to set up our
form if we use ng model it will bind
this new message property to the
component type script and then if the
user clicks the Enter key we'll go ahead
and submit their chat message and just
for good measure will also add a submit
button for users that don't have an
Enter key that takes care of the front
end code but there's still one thing
that we have to address to really make
this a usable feature as I mentioned
earlier this data model will only work
up to one megabyte at which point
firestore will start rejecting new
messages we can actually address this
with a very simple cloud function that
just listens to the incoming messages
and if we get over a certain point it
will just either archive or delete the
oldest messages if you look over here on
the left I'm adding new messages and
once I get over ten it's going to start
deleting messages on the right that's my
cloud function working in the background
and I don't know if something change
recently but there's almost no latency
on these requests the cloud function
round-trip finishes in just a few
hundred milliseconds so I already have
cloud functions initialized in this
project with typescript and the only
thing I'm doing is importing the admin
SDK and initializing it then we'll go
ahead and define firestore as our
database then we can name our function
archive chat then we'll have it point to
our chat collection and only run when
the document is updated the purpose of
this function is to look at the current
size of the messages array if there's
more than 50 messages in there or if the
messages characters are greater than
10,000 then we'll want to start deleting
or archiving those messages it's not
actually implemented here but you could
use json stringify to check the total
length of the object as a string then
you can roughly estimate the total size
of the document based on the length of
that string so if we determine that the
array is too big then we'll go ahead and
start splicing items from the beginning
of that array or the oldest messages
then you'll also notice that I'm setting
this up as a batch right because you
might want to add the deleted messages
to some other location if that is the
case you definitely want to make this an
atomic batch because you don't want the
delete operation to succeed and the
update to fail then you would lose those
messages forever and lastly we'll just
go ahead and return null if
these conditions are not met we won't
make any update to the existing document
now we have a basic chat feature up and
running make sure to check out the link
in the description and play around with
the live demo based on this code if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and I realize that we went
through that code pretty fast but I'm
working on a fully fledged chat feature
for the ionic course which will be
released in the next week or two so if
you want to see more features at a
slightly slower pace than I recommend
upgrading to a pro membership to get
access to that course thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon